so der wolf ist los in schwanewede in
niedersachsen und er versetzt die
menschen in helle aufregung insbesondere
den ansässigen landwirten und schäfern
bereite der schlaflose nächte denn
reihenweise reist das hierzulande unter
artenschutz stehenden raubtiere deren
vier die bauern fordern jetzt eine
strengere kontrolle der bestände
ländliche idylle glückliche lämmchen und
zufriedene schafe
doch diese idylle findet ein jähes ende
aus der beschaulichen bio weide wird ein
blutiger tatort aufgerissene körper
verteilt auf der grünen weide die opfer
schafe erbarmungslos gehetzt
abgeschlachtet und das ist der täter
mitten in der nacht dringen vermutlich
mehrere wölfe auf die weide zwischen
sich an ihre art losen opfer heran und
fallen urplötzlich über sie her wüten in
der schafherde als biobauer carsten bode
am nächsten morgen nach seiner herde
sieht überkommt ihn das nackte grauen
der fürchterliche anblick das leid der
tiere auch für den gestandenen bauern
eine hohe emotionale belastung man kann
nichts machen man muss zusehen wie die
tiere letztendlich in qualen
dahinvegetieren und
das ist man kann sich das einfach nicht
vorstellen dass man so immer zu haben
für drei der unter artenschutz stehenden
vier hufe kommt jede hilfe zu spät nach
rücksprache mit den ämtern hält der
tierarzt die erlaubnis er erlöst die
tiere von ihrem leid rund zehn schafe
überleben schwer verletzt werden jetzt
fürsorglich von carsten bode und seiner
frau versorgt
und der heißt es angesprochen
wenn das jetzt weiter an spielt quasi
das der situation mittel genau
und das bedeutet dass keine bakterien
sich da bilden bzw das kann fliegen
und
die entzündung dabei tut carsten bode
alles dafür genau das zu verhindern
sichert sein gelände wie vor knox mit
stahl zaun und stacheldraht unter großer
kraftanstrengung selbst finanziert die
hoffnung hier kommt kein wolf rüber vom
schutzherr ausreichend geschützt das
habe ich also immer gedacht gehabt seit
2014 besteht dieser zaun und das ist uns
trifft das halte ich an die nie für
möglich gehalten ich habe heute morgen
heulte wie ich die tiere gesehen habe
dass das kann man sich einfach nicht
vorstellen
der finanzielle schaden für den bio
landwirt beachtlich die behandlung der
tiere die entsorgung der kadaver der
landwirt muss sämtliche kosten
übernehmen eigentlich übernimmt der bund
in solchen fällen die haftung wälzt
diese aber auf den landwirt ab und das
aus einem unfassbaren grund der zaun
biete angeblich nicht genug schutz der
wolf könne zu leicht auf die weide
eindringen wir haben schon ich würde mal
sagen halbes fort knox hier aufgebaut
und dann
merkt man trotzdem das reicht nicht man
ist hilflos carsten bode fühlt sich im
stich gelassen
arbeitet er doch eigentlich auch für den
erhalt bedrohter tierarten setzt auf
eine nachhaltige und tierfreundliche
haltung der tiere das ende ist die
stallhaltung anders können wir das nicht
mehr bezahlen das ist einfach von der
nabu von denen die einfach so gewollt
aber das kann man durch
dass er die schafe jetzt notgedrungen im
stall unterbringen muss für ihn ein
widerspruch